what are the biggest mistakes you see
new screenwriters make our first
screenplay you mean literally or
structurally the dialogue character
because the biggest mistakes they make
is usually their personalities but but
of the actual writer or yeah okay but
that aside I think the biggest mistake
is is over explaining and not knowing
how to tunnel the background of the
story into the story instead of laying
it out like we just developed a
brilliant screenplay the last several
years in which the opening conversation
just is not convincing because there is
no other explanation for the words in
the conversation other than explaining
to the audience what's going on and and
that's a hard to avoid mistake because
you know you've got to explain what's
going on but if you do it overtly the
audience is gonna not believe the
dialogue they're not gonna believe you
know they're gonna not be able to
suspend their disbelief so you have to
sneak these things in to the story at
times when they're needed and not too
much too soon one of the common mistake
the route mistake beneath that mistake
is thinking that the audience is not as
smart as they are it's it's looking down
on your audience because respecting the
audience is essential to good
storytelling you have to believe in the
audience and you know imagine sitting on
this country porch and telling the story
with no audience right I find that very
hard to imagine because storytelling is
about audiences you you can immediately
start telling the story if even one
person shows up but sitting there and
telling about yourself that isn't what a
story is right so if one person shows up
and it's Jackie you're gonna tell it
differently than if Sally showed up
first
and a Sally and Jackie they're together
you're gonna tell it differently than
you would have to either one of them by
themselves that's just the nature of
human communication so not respecting
the audience or not realizing that it's
all about the audience it's probably the
biggest mistake and it takes a while to
get out of that mistake because the only
way to get out of it is through constant
feedback that tells you it's not
necessary because somebody told me once
like an editor is the person who tells a
writer when to stop writing and I
thought that was a actually a lot of
truth to that because how's it right are
gonna know unless somebody says you
don't need that and I think that that is
often the case with first green writers
as they they put a lot of things than
they don't need we need much less then
then you think we do we don't need a
scene to come to an you know to come to
an end it's okay to cut out of it I mean
writers are constantly have a great line
at the end of the same that then they
add a couple of more lines their
insecurity lines they call them so we
instantly just cross them out because
they already had a great line that's the
end of the same and yes everything
hasn't been quite wrapped up but that's
that adds energy when you cut that
you're pouring energy into the story
when you leave it there you're sucking
energy out of the story because the
audience is like bored through those
last two lines and going or do we need
that I was I'm out of it it you know you
had me at a low kind of you know and I
think that's probably the most common
mistake is right over writing just over
writing you said earlier personality
just well screenwriters have to be
careful what their personalities because
by nature they're very overtly at least
self-confident you know aggressive
people mostly that's a mask for lack of
self-confidence which is a normal thing
for a writer to have we all have that no
matter what stage you reach you'll
always have the lack of self-confidence
but then the world's divided into those
who do it anyway and those who let that
stop them from doing
you know every actor has that before he
goes on stage some of the greatest
actors Richard Chamberlain used to throw
up before he went on stage and and but
he went on stage I mean it was just part
of what he did you know you get nervous
before you sorry and that's not a bad
thing that's a good thing you know if
you weren't nervous then you're not
doing something important so you know if
you're going into battle on the
battlefield or you should you be afraid
yes if you weren't afraid
HP you'd be nuts so I think that that's
what happens in personality is that
sometimes people are compensate in an
over aggressive way and it's an
automatic turn off because one of the
several things about succeeding in
Hollywood is don't get on everyone's
life is too short list yeah I mean and
it's really true I mean that it's
sometimes you get on it immediately and
you'll never get off of it it's very
hard to break it and and you have to you
know realize that you you need to act
with the people in the business the way
you would act with true friends and who
will tell you you're an if
you're being an and the
Hollywood won't they'll just say thank
you so much for coming well we'll be in
touch with you and you know that'll be
the end of it but I'll go you
know as soon as he's out of the room and
demanding it's part of demanding because
there's a kind of petulance that sets in
the longer a writer has worked without
you know reward and an acclamation and
compensation and it's almost like I
deserve this you're going to give it to
me now you know I had an actress at
dinner one night in the middle of dinner
she said you know a lot of other people
she said I demand attention now and it
was really funny because the men thought
that was cute and the women did not they
did not she was not reinvade 'add oh no
no the women definitely did not like
that petulance because you know men
thought it was sure cute because she was
sexy and so on but in today's world pets
especially Hollywood where the stakes
are so high everybody wants
you know thousands of people are lined
up for every single position you could
ask for and they want people who are
cool and professional not hot-headed and
demanding and when I see a writer is of
the latter category I just kind of run
for the hills and I can NO nasc writer
is not that way when he's modest and so
on I will continue talking doing four
years even before I represent him or
work with him until I find something
that no I can work with because he's so
respectful and so you know not on I
choose to shortlist
you know he's that that's a very rare
thing but it's it's important when you
think about it any walk of life you know
you're not gonna the the uncle who you
can't stand to see it Thanksgiving is
not the one that you want to be
representing or making a movie with is
that I'm sorry to interrupt it is that
when someone's too self aggrandizing
like it's just this is the greatest
thing and there they won't take no for
an answer and it just comes yeah that's
part of it because you don't tell us how
great it is just tell us the story get
out of the way you know of the story
well we don't want to hear about we want
to hear this - your first pitch we don't
want to hear you know you haven't done
this much we want to hear that you
practice this and that you know exactly
what to say we want to see if you've got
the goods and that is the story like
Mark Twain said don't tell us the fat
lady is going to sing bring her out let
her sink you know that that's that's
what we want to see in other words don't
draw attention to yourself because that
is not what we're interested in we're
interested in the story and maybe we'll
get too interested in you later like
after you brought a couple of good
stories and then we go by the way you
know where you from and you know what's
your story but we don't want to deal
with her at the beginning because the
truth is no matter who you are if your
story is good we love you you know we
look because you told this story and
that's that's a great you know kind of
equalizer when you think about it
it's a real world of ideas
but if you start telling us about
yourself and give us the chance to hate
you before where you even started
telling the story that ik how stupid is
that and I have to say that years ago I
rarely I stopped taking writers to
pitches of their stories because they
most of the time unsold the story after
they sold it for a very simple reason
they weren't looking at the buyer
they were in a coma they were telling
story and they weren't watching the
buyers eyes which is all it matters in a
pitch like I can see immediately if
you're bored and I'm gonna you know if
I'm any value at all I'll switch to
another story to pitch you you know
because there's that's what the the
buyer is thinking can I do do I like
this story can I do something with it
but sometimes you'll just hear one word
dragon and that'll be it click my eyes
go like let's see I've got a 350 and
then I've got a 330 like my brain is
thinking about other things because I
know I can't acquire a dragon story so
why am I wasting this person's time well
the person's not even listening and
looking at he so he goes on talking and
and but the other thing happens too he's
already said enough to sell you you're
totally this is what you're looking for
I can see it in your eyes but he keeps
talking so after a while now the buyer
is looking at him instead of listening
to the story he's looking at him going
why is this guy still talking I love
this I want to ask some questions you
know what I mean so that's an example of
a writer forgetting about the most
important part of his story which is the
audience his audience the reader the
audience is the most important part of
the story and when you forget it they
know to read or know so you forgotten
them and then they're there to doubt
they close the book
you